hello and welcome to this video on
playing Michael Hennigan from the UK so
he's the king boobs he's the Kings
Indian guy so kind of easy to predict
that we would get something like that
each sex okay maybe Bishop g5 yet so
maybe even thought that Bishop g5 is
removed to prevent him c6 could be an
idea for black trying to go d5 I will
see those positions are notoriously
tricky look simple but there are many
many hidden subtleties since really
wants to go for a 5m
it looks a bit strange to be honest with
the night own age 7 and so on but would
seem yeah at least some head on the
clock those English opening setups quite
often can be played quickly so and now
h5 Wow hmm yeah I can play h4 it's not
like this is totally out of the question
okay maybe things I don't really see him
I mean how does black hear exactly how
does black play without the f porn it's
very difficult to imagine and this this
has I mean age 5 is kind of weakening
maybe he wants to go F 4 in this
position when he could theoretically
speaking like f4 ef ef Bishop takes rook
takes therefore yes something something
drastic him Wow
this is the kind of wow moment okay so
f4 is kind of normal here let's go ahead
for and see where he goes with the Queen
they have 95 for example 2690 fires very
annoying for black and 95 is annoying in
any case but wow okay isn't that that
looks weird okay so how was it like that
so what's the product thing is I'm a
much better developed I mean much better
so there should be a ideas here to open
it up e4 as possible also take and do d
4 is an idea I Scott c6 coming though ok
I'll go I go with this see that c6 is
not so easily playable not not easy not
an easy decision
my general idea is to take on e5 and
play d4 so that f4 eyes opened up ok
I'll Dover go with this mustard it
should be strategically correct him open
open it up while I better developed
yeah night f four fingers which night
even this night is kind of interesting
yeah I think I'll go further go with
this and then take age five it's a bit
weird with the Kings being a little bit
open
okay let's get scrubber porn
so green g6 would go into some ending a
poner I think I'll do that just keep it
simple here still a reasonably weird
position where I could blunder so just
the better ending is good he's six okay
and it opens up the a for awesome
somewhat hmm check okay let's do this
first so g 4g phone and take here
maybe I should have played b6 I should
have played b6 that would have been a
good more just intermediate move he can
take be five now and that leads down
yeah make it look a little bit strange
sure play b6 and now be 6 doesn't do all
that much and so I grab ya the night is
saying I have no tech to have a tactic i
have f6e actually i could try that f6
rook takes f7 checking of eight Bishop
e3 do that would work have six so ever
may be a b5 I then have rook takes again
it's actually quite interesting let's do
it
the rock now covers the mite is that way
to get this promoted now have seven no
my idea was to take here actually so I'm
going to do it then probably winning on
time is near some time about seven so
maybe here and yeah it's a tempo and
before next for Bishop h6 a ok this is
slack for fats aren't I'm pretty strong
you have to voice his Bishop a 20 ok
this is shy this is actually leading to
made poo tougher he played in a very
enterprising way on the King side but it
it has many weaknesses this position and
so castles n LG five you had this yeah
the engine degrees in it gives gives me
all or almost a winning position already
which is a bit much it's ok white white
should be better here ok and DF for or
d44 is the engine move and maybe got a
better development e and he is attacking
pretty much yeah unprepared is a bit
strong but it is not very well prepared
ok yet now around he assists the thing
this was because I was slightly
irritated by c6 this is why I went b5 a
computer things that's ok so this one
and
takes takes d4 and just open up
everything is that also what the engine
wants to do at the engine just to take
here uncle Jake's and then deform ok ok
that's certainly quite logical yeah
surprisingly I thought you should take
here at least so I mean that doesn't it
doesn't look good this snow is not this
one here this one on Queen takes not
quite sure it must be nicer i also have
sometimes i have bishop like this or the
rope can come over it's pretty nice but
this is basically the same thing upon
down yeah Queen g6 is not the best move
but I wanted to have a simple game and
here I should have checked here should
have played b 6i believe or let's say
here here and now be six this is even a
bit clearer yeah not giving you the file
and he cannot capture as rupee six is
quite terrible it was technically a
little bit more precise but it's still
win this yeah I cannot take because
check this is check winning there's a
note a exam dirty ghetto some time but
it's not much that he can do he played
hook c2 would I expected something else
like stay on the a farm then I have you
for with Bishop age 6 coming and it's
not engines on plus 18 it's a bit much
yeah I think it was probably a little
bit too aggressive what
right there okay well thanks for
watching